all right let's get into Friday feedback
where we hear uh from some of you your
messages across different platforms you
can email info davidpackman.com feel
free to leave a comment on YouTube it
might be featured here or post something
to the subreddit really whatever you
prefer first one is from Wolfie Wolfie
says Mr Pacman hello I've been watching
your content nearly five years since
Trump's bizarre presidency but I do have
a bizarre yeah I do have a question to
ask you I'm okay with your opinion and
I'd rather keep it between us well I
don't do that it's all either on the air
or or not at all but we'll keep you
Anonymous what is your view on lgbtq
same-sex marriage and the whole things
relating to it I am a gay male but I
think as an outcast it's totally getting
kind of corporate anyway just wanted
your opinion I mean you can share it on
YouTube but I'd rather remain anonymous
good you we are keeping you Anonymous
Wolfie could be anybody uh my views on
lgbtq same-sex marriage and all of it I
have been a staunch and Powerful Ally
for the LGBT community for as long as
I've been doing this show I've been an
advocate for gay marriage for as long as
I've been doing this show these these
aren't even controversial or contentious
issues for me
um and we have been
following the evolution of the political
and social narrative around those issues
for more than a decade and a half on the
show and so there are probably hundreds
of videos that I have done on the
subject there are also for newer viewers
or or listeners of the show
at least a couple dozen interviews that
I've done over the years with overt
rancid homophobes of different kinds and
flavors and sorts and more recently as
I'm sure people who have been following
the political discourse are aware
in the United States
the homophobes have shifted towards
transphobia and focusing on the trans
Community you know there's a movement on
the right which loves to say
there is no more
hyper-represented group in the United
States than LGBT folks you've got a you
know a pride flag at the United Nations
there's Pride parades there's uh
everything gay pride month this is a
group that is so overrepresented
relative to their size in the population
you know the Counterpoint I would make
to that is this is a group on whom there
is so much Focus because for decades the
right just can't leave folks alone
and has activated first it was we need
to defend marriage remember when that
was the whole thing then all of a sudden
there's gay marriage we've had it for
years everything's fine nothing bad has
happened now the focus is on trans
people so to those who say it's an
over-represented movement relative to
its population
the obsession seems to be coming from
the right and from those who want to
take rights away all right Wolfie so I
hope that that's I hope it's clear and I
hope I'm uh kind of giving you a a
perspective on My Views Eleanor wrote In
from California about Maga Preppers this
is interesting Eleanor says hey David I
fell down a right-wing rabbit hole and
noticed some alarming things Maga
Twitter feeds are filled with ads for
survival gear for the end days after
they defeat the left in the Civil War
they're advertising pamphlets on how to
protect yourself legally if you shoot
someone self-defense laws Etc
fascinating and terrifying at the same
time so this is this is an interesting
thing
prepping
has a religious component for some now I
want to be really clear don't email me
saying the Preppers aren't only
religious right people I know that there
is non-religious right-wing prepping and
there is also left-wing prepping I I
understand that I'm a very casual
prepper myself very casual I have like a
can of tuna under the desk taped in case
there's even an emergency I can pull it
out and just eat it I guess I'd need a
can opener but I'll deal with that later
um
but there has been a history
of religiously oriented prepping in the
Mormon faith prepping is a big thing but
also an Evangelical uh Christian circles
there's been shows like the Jim Baker
show and others Alex Jones products have
had a prepping aspect to it that is
maybe a little less overtly religiously
based but but it's still there so that's
not surprised at all what they've done
recently is they've just shifted the
reasoning
10 12 years ago a lot of it was like the
Rapture
uh you've got to be prepared for the
apocalypse and when all of that happens
you're going to want to have this food
storage now it has shifted a lot to you
know there's this Marxist dystopia that
we're heading towards where there will
be no food availability or if we have
another pandemic the Liberals will shut
down the food supply so you better have
it so the language has changed around it
but there's actually Maga prepping is
just the latest sort of outcropping or
protuberance of what is a much larger
right wing and often religiously
oriented prepping community and when
they add in the gun elements to it it is
it is certainly scary stuff Graham wrote
in and says hey David welcome back hope
you enjoyed a nice break guess your uh
your guest hosts did an excellent job as
always and Graham goes on to say
I'm sure it hasn't escaped your
attention but I noticed the following
your YouTube subscribers right before
the right wing hate mob
1.66 million your YouTube subscribers
after the right wing hate mob over
1.69 million seems that went well for
them eh exactly as I said in the
previous message the whole thing created
noise and it probably made a bunch of
new people go and check out your channel
thinking to themselves this guy seems
like a rare sensible voice and end up
subscribing I know it's been painful
from the standpoint of advertisers but I
find it difficult not to be amused by
how poorly this worked out for the mob
yeah listen I've said to people the
entire tweet Scandal regarding my tweet
about the Nashville shooting and prayer
and it getting all the way to Donald
Trump Jr posting about me and Candace
Owens and others David Pacman does not
have a soul he doesn't all right it
would have been uniquely good were it
not for the fact that people started
harassing my dad and other people online
right and the the death threats in all
of it it would have been uniquely good
now that everybody's forgotten about it
a lot of the good is left we've got like
40 000 new subscribers on YouTube and we
had like a thousand people signed up for
paid subscriptions on the website all of
that
um but yeah Graham is Right which is to
some degree this backfired on the right
wing mob let's look at our subreddit
user radage posted I find it funny how
failed former president Trump is touting
Florida as third worst in the country
for many things in his so-called
statement stating how Florida is third
worst in coveted cases third worst in
covet deaths third worst in crimes
doesn't that strike anyone as no wonder
since Florida is the third most populous
state in the nation and no relevance
whatsoever that Ron De Santa monius was
governor does he really think his
followers are that dumb to take his
claims without a grain of salt well yeah
his followers are accepting those claims
without questioning them the reality
about Florida is a very mediocre story
now I know people will write to me I'll
say but David you go to Florida all the
time and you talk about how great it is
I enjoy certain parts of Florida that is
absolutely true I also am aware of the
real coveted numbers in Florida
per capita when you look at covid
numbers per capita in Florida adjusted
to the population
Florida's very mediocre it's not nearly
the worst death rate and it's not nearly
the lowest death rate it's not nearly
the worst case rate or that it's just a
mediocre State overall in many ways
there are parts of Florida that are
doing well and parts of Florida that are
doing less well
but economically as far as education
goes as far as all these things
Florida's very mediocre and what's funny
is Trump used to talk about how great
Florida was when he wanted to talk about
how the the approach to the pandemic
from right-wing States was better now
he's saying Florida is terrible it's the
same Florida it's just Trump's telling a
different story about it from the
YouTube channel YouTube user Douglas
ducote clown says Maga now stands for my
ass got arrested which is funny but then
another user protest 2A which I can only
imagine means Second Amendment
has a blistering conspiracy theory about
the Trump arrest this user says he was
not arrested didn't ride in a cop car
didn't get handcuffed Dems just made the
biggest mistake because they got nothing
on him it's already backfiring we'll see
well yeah we will see that is a wild
conspiracy theory that there really was
no arrest of course there was there are
real fair questions as to what will
happen in the polling thanks to the
arrest it seems it's a little helpful
for Trump in the Republican primary but
probably damaging in the general
election if Trump makes it that far but
we will see but Trump didn't really get
arrested as really something else one
other note about the Trump arrest and
this is a really good point Spicy Dragon
posted quote I guess New York City isn't
so big and scary as to keep the
Republicans away true a bunch of these
Republicans who always talk about how
dangerous New York City is
swarmed into the city for Trump's arrest
ask how many of them were terrified or
attacked while here did any of them
actually go and show crime I'm a
lifelong New York City girl and have
never been attacked mugged or murdered
yet as far as I know LOL yeah I mean
listen my experience in New York City is
regularly one where I never even see
crime obviously big cities have crime uh
what is important of course is what are
the crime rates how do the crime rates
uh separate from or contrast with the
narrative about democratically Led
cities are the most dangerous we know
that's not true we know about the red
State murder problem we know about all
of these things but it is interesting
that there was not a single story all of
these Trump supporters who came into New
York City for the arrest not a single
story of even witnessing a crime never
never mind even being the victim of such
a crime and remember the crime rate
including property crime and violent
crime is higher in Oklahoma City than it
is in New York City those are the facts
they're not very convenient for many on
the right all right we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com when you do that you
really do get access to the bonus show
instantly oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
very much so use the coupon code 24
starts now we'll see you on the bonus
show or otherwise I'll be back with you
on Monday